[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
My name Sandeep, and I'm a
developer advocate at Google.
Today I'll be bringing
you some quick tips
to get started on
Google Compute Engine.
Setting up your Google
Cloud Platform account.
Before we jump
into doing things,
let's set up your account.
If you already have one,
you can just skip forward.
The first thing you need
is a Google account.
If you use Gmail, Google+,
YouTube, or Android,
you already have one of these.
When you sign up
for the trial, it'll
ask you for credit
card information.
But we won't charge you unless
you upgrade your account.
And don't worry about your code.
We automatically
pause your account
after the free
trial is over so you
can upgrade when you're ready.
You can see a free trial
page for more information.
Using the Cloud Launcher to
quickly deploy WordPress.
So you want to get your
website up and running fast.
The best way to do this is
to use the Cloud Launcher.
Here you can select
preconfigured images
and launch them in
just a few clicks.
Let's go to cloud.google.com
to get started.
Make sure you are logged
into your Google account.
If you can see your picture
and the My Console link,
you're good to go.
Now click the Launcher link.
Welcome to the Cloud Launcher.
The launcher has hundreds
of preconfigured images
from Google and
partners such as Bitnami
that you can launch
with just a few clicks.
In our case, we want to
start a WordPress website.
So we click on the
WordPress Google Click
to Deploy solution.
Here we can see typical
cost for the solution
and what is included.
By default, it launches
an n1-standard-1 machine
with an additional
100 gigabytes of disk
and the estimated monthly
cost is around $35.84.
Using the Pricing Calculator
to estimate pricing.
Before we keep going,
I'm going to show you
how you can customize your
estimate by using the pricing
calculator.
While the free trial makes
it easy to experiment
until you find your
perfect solution,
it's a good idea to use
the pricing calculator
to estimate your costs.
This way you can create a
combination that works for you.
On cloud.google.com,
click the Pricing link.
Then click on Get
a Custom Quote.
Here you can play with
different configurations
to get the set up that
fits your budget and needs.
For this example, I'm going
to be hosting a small website.
So I have one server.
And I select a free operating
system and a g1 small instance
type.
The server is going to be
running all day and all night,
so these numbers look good.
So I also like the
g1 small instance
with 50 gigabytes of disk space.
The monthly cost comes
to around $18.35.
This looks great, but remember
it is only an estimate,
and your actual cost can vary.
Now that we found
the image we want
to deploy and the estimated
costs, it's time to deploy it.
Let's go back to
the Cloud Launcher
and select the WordPress image.
The first thing we want to
do is click Get Started.
Now, select the project
you want to deploy into
or create a new one.
I've already created
one for this example,
so I'm going to select that one.
Now we see the
configuration page.
For the Google Click
to Deploy solutions,
the configuration section
will be customized
for that particular solution.
For WordPress, the options
are rather straightforward.
I can change my
zone if I want, then
I select the g1
small instance like I
configured in the
pricing section
and set the disk
to 50 gigabytes.
Then I type in my admin email.
I also make sure that
phpmyadmin is checked.
Once I click Deploy WordPress,
the wheels start turning.
As you can see, deployment
can take around four to five
minutes to complete,
so I'm going
to fast forward this section.
After a few minutes, we can
see our WordPress instance
is up and running.
Configuring firewalls
and networks.
Now that the
instance is running,
I'm going to show
you how to access it.
The first step is to
configure the firewall
to allow HTTP traffic.
Go to cloud.google.com, then
select the My Console link.
Select the project
you are working on.
Click Compute, Compute
Engine, and VM Instances.
Click the External IP and
check Enable HTTP option.
If you want to make
some more complex rules,
we've got to visit
the Network section.
Click Network on
the side panel, then
select the network
you want to modify.
In most cases, you just need
to modify the default network.
Here, we can see all the rules
for the whole default network.
You may notice that HTTP
rule we made is not here,
and that is because that rule is
only for the specific machine.
If you want all machines
on the default network
to expose port 80, this is
the best place to do it.
So let's add a firewall rule
and then call the rule HTTP.
Then type 0.0.0.0/0 to allow
anyone to access our website
and open up TCP port 80, which
is the standard HTTP port.
Click Create.
Now, all machines on the default
network have port 80 open.
To delete a Click To
Deploy deployment,
go to your Developer Console.
Go to the Manage section,
and then go to Deployments.
Click the Trash icon to
delete the deployment.
While Click to Deploy
is awesome and includes
a lot of prebuilt stacks like
MEAN, LAMP, LAMP Rails, and all
the Bitnami images,
sometimes you
want to roll your
own custom set up.
Google Cloud Platform
makes this easy to do.
Before we go any further,
I want to mention
that Google Cloud has
an awesome command line
interface and the REST
interface that you
can use to create, deploy, and
manage pretty much anything
on the platform from VMs
to storage to databases.
You can see how this can
make automation really easy.
For this video, I'll be doing
mostly everything from the GUI,
but you might notice little
equivalent Rest and Command
Line links down below.
So everything I'm doing
can be replicated via REST
on Command Line as well.
The first thing I'm going
to do is go to My Console.
Then I'll go to the compute
section and the VM instances
section.
Now click Create Instance.
Here we can see the
config page, and we
can give our instance a
name and choose a zone.
It's a good idea to
choose a zone that's
close to your customers.
Then we can pick a machine type.
Pick the right machine
type for your workload.
I'm going to pick an
n1-standard1 to start with.
Now we choose the
boot image and disk.
You can see all the
options we offer,
from Debian to Windows Server,
to Enterprise Red Hat Linux.
You can even create
your own image
or use a previous snapshot.
I like Ubuntu 14.04 LTS so
that's what I'm going to use.
I also want it to use
an SSD disk, which
is much faster, although
slightly more expensive.
We can also open the HTTP
and HTTPS ports right here,
saving us a trip to
the Network section.
At this point, we
can create our VM.
But I want to talk about the
advanced optional settings.
If we had a fleet
of machines, we
can give each one individual
tags to categorize them.
You can also specify a startup
script that will run on boot.
I like to set up a
script that installs
Docker and automatically
pulls and starts
my containers without
having me type anything.
In the Disk section, you
can add additional disks
to your machine.
I highly recommend
creating a disk
for storing application data
and not storing your application
data on the boot disk.
In the Network
section, you can choose
if you want temporary IP
address or a static IP address.
The temporary
address will change
every time you
reboot your machine,
while the static
address stays the same,
and you can actually move
it between instances.
I like the static
addresses because it
makes configuring
DNS and upgrading
machine types that much easier.
Note, you will be charged
for unused static addresses,
so make sure you use
them if you make them.
In the Axis and Security
section you can add SSH keys
and enable access to other
Google Cloud Platform APIs
by default.
Now let's hit Create, and
you can see it chugging away
in the background.
In a few seconds,
and I'm serious,
the VM is up and running.
We get an SSH into our box by
clicking the little SSH button.
If we launch the Windows Server,
we would get an RDP option
instead.
You can also download
an SSH key to use
or if you've installed
the Google Cloud
SDK that I previously mentioned,
you can get SSH directly
from there as well.
Now you can do anything
you want with your VM.
Backups, increasing
disk capacity,
and upgrading servers.
Now that your server is up and
running and getting popular,
it's important to know how to
back up your VM and upgrade it.
Thankfully, Google Compute
Engine makes it easy.
To make a backup of
your disk, all you do
is go to the snapshot section,
click Create Snapshot,
select the disk, and bam.
After a few seconds,
a snapshot is created.
And using the REST or
Command Line interface,
you can easily
automate this process.
You can use this snapshot to
create new virtual machines
or use it to restore your
server to a previous state.
Now let's look at how we
can upgrade a machine. .
I want to do four things.
1) Attach a new 100 gigabyte
disk for application data.
2) Grow this new disk
to 500 gigabytes.
3) Grow my boot disk from 10
gigabytes of 50 gigabytes.
4) Go from a 1 core machine
to a 4 core machine.
1) Attach a new disk
to a running instance.
Let's look at how we can
attach a new blank disk
to a running instance.
Click the instance you
want to attach the disk to,
then go to the disk section
and select New Disk.
Let's set it to
use an empty image
with 100 gigabytes of space.
Now that the disk is
physically attached to the VM,
we need to mount it.
For the rest of
the tutorial, I'm
going to be running Linux
commands on an Ubuntu system.
These commands should work
for most Linux systems,
but your particular machine
might be a little different.
SSH into the machine by
clicking the SSH button.
Then let's look at all the disks
using the LS block command.
Here we can see
our boot disk SDA 1
is mounted as the
root directory.
We can also see a
new disk called SDB,
and there's no mount point.
Let's fix that.
First, make a new directory
to mount our disk.
Let's call it mount app data.
Run sudo mkdir mnt app data
to make our new directory.
Then Google Cloud
Platform provides a script
to automatically format
the disk and mount it.
Run this command, which will
format and mount the disk.
If the disk was
preformatted, we could
use the standard
mount command here.
Once that is done,
we can run lsblk
and see the disk is mounted.
2) Increase the size of
an attached data disk.
Let's say you want to
increase the application disk
size from 100 gigabytes
to 500 gigabytes
because your data is growing.
The first thing you want
to do is stop your server.
This will try to
perform a clean shutdown
so you don't lose any data that
might be written to the disk.
then create a
snapshot of the disk.
After this is done,
go to the disk section
and create a new disk.
It is very important that
you create this new disk
in the same zone as the VM.
Select the snapshot we just
created and set the size
to 500 gigabytes.
Now let's go to the Instances
screen, click our server,
remove the old disk
from the instance,
and attach the new one.
Now, if you boot
up your machine,
we can run lsblk command,
and the disk is there.
We can mount it using the
following mount command.
And if you run
the df -h command,
you can see the disk
space has not increased.
It still says 100 gigabytes.
This is because the snapshot we
used is set to old disk size.
We need to resize the partition
to use the full 500 gigabytes.
First, unmount the drive with
sudo umount mnt app data.
While you technically
can resize a drive that's
currently mounted, it is
safer to unmount the drive.
Run sudo e2fsck -f and the
name the drive, sdb, then
run sudo resize2fs and the
name of the drive, again, sdb.
After that is done,
run the mount command
again to remount your drive.
Now you can see we get the
full 500 gigabytes of disk,
and it only took four commands.
Easy.
Re-size the boot disk and
upgrade your machine type.
In order to upgrade your
boot disk or upgrade your VM,
you need to follow
basically the same process.
This process requires you to
create a brand-new instance
and delete the old one.
First, make sure
your VM is stopped.
Then create a snapshot
of the boot disk.
Then create a new disk
using the snapshot.
Make sure the zone
and size are correct.
Now we need to delete
the old instance.
Double check that the
snapshot and disk are created,
because deletion is permanent.
After this is done, we need
to create a new instance
to use this new disk.
Let's select a four
core machine and use
the new disk we just created.
Remember to attach the
old data disk as well.
Once the machine is created, we
need to reuse our old static IP
address so we know how to
reconfigure any DNS settings.
Go to the Network section and
select the static IP address.
If you're [AUDIO OUT]
this video [AUDIO OUT]
for unused resources.
First, let's look at
the Instances page.
Here [AUDIO OUT] VMs.
To stop [AUDIO OUT] your VMs
that [AUDIO OUT] using but
want to use in the future.
This is like shutting
down your PC.
While you're not
charged for stopped VMs,
remember that you are
still paying for the disk.
If you want to
completely remove the VM,
use the Delete function.
By default, this will remove
the VM and the boot disk.
This action is permanent.
So if you want to be safe,
make a snapshot of your desk
before deleting.
Now, let's see how we can
remove old disks and snapshots.
If we go to disks [AUDIO OUT]
notice I [AUDIO OUT]
delete to a machine [AUDIO OUT]
Disks that are not attached
can be deleted by selecting
the disk and clicking Delete.
Some disks, like boot
disks, cannot be unattached.
The only way to
delete these disks
is to delete the
[AUDIO OUT] VM as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I hope you enjoyed this quick
tutorial on getting started
with Google Compute Engine.
I can't wait to
see what you build.
[MUSIC PLAYING]